hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one additional
feature of Aristophanes speech as he
delivers it in Plato's symposium is this
connection between maleness and male
male attraction and all that goes along
with that and political life so we're
gonna look at how that actually plays
itself out you might think of it as he's
advancing a claim about the nature of
human beings and the attractions that
they have where they take their
pleasures where they take their desires
and moving from that to a discussion
about the nature of politics and why
politics itself is going to be male
centric male-dominated
so that those who are are more you know
directed towards the male in terms of
their their attractions their erotic
their erotic orientation are also going
to be more effective in terms of
politics in a large respect this is a
function not only of you know that the
patriarchal nature of most ancient
societies but in particular of that of
Athens where there was a very rigid
distinction between not only male and
female in terms of you know occupation
and activities but also in terms of
space
so there were you know public affairs
and those were male-dominated affairs
those those are things of the man and
then there are domestic affairs that was
the province of the woman you see this
carried forward in the rest of Greece as
well but it's particularly acute in
democratic Athens which is where
Aristophanes is from and where the
symposium is being given so we start up
with this this note of men attracted to
men and you know where did that come
from
a little bit of review here we've talked
about this in the other videos
originally there were three types of you
know races or sexes however you want to
put the term Guinea in terms of human
being there are there were these
creatures that were like us except they
were doubled they had two faces two sets
of arms or four arms four legs and two
sets of reproductive organs and some of
them were male-female all right so one
set of male organs one set of female
organs the androgynous ones you know man
on the Rose woman goon a some more
female female and others were male male
2 sets of male organs zoo splits them
down the middle there's a whole
discussion about why that happens I
don't need to go into here the result of
this is that each one of us as the human
being as we are today is looking for our
missing half that's what the force of
eros or love or erotic desire really
amounts to is is this this inchoate and
in many respects not quite conscious
effort to find what it is that will
complete us and so for Aristophanes the
the men who were originally part of this
male male composite or really not a
competent we think of it as a composite
from our perspective but we're
originally one being with you know the
two male sex organs split down the
middle they're looking for a male other
half so how does this manifest itself in
their youth they spend time with with
other you know youths or males with men
they enjoy their company
they engage in those sort of activities
they don't really want to have anything
to do with the girls or the women that
would be one way you can tell the
difference between men who are going to
be attracted to women later on do they
hang out with women at all at least from
Aristophanes going to do once they're
mature then they start seeking out
lovers or or the beloved alright
remember we have this rather it's not
unique but but you know it is typical to
the Greek society of the time where you
have an older man and a youth and the
older man is the lumber he's the one
pursues the youth is the beloved there
was some shame attached to this if
penetration is taking place we've
already talked about the paradoxes of
love when we got the Pazhani as a speech
but in this case it's being driven by
this desire right erotic desire to find
ones missing yeah so once a man is
mature he seeks out lovers or beloved
and he gives as Aristophanes says he
gives his love to youths there's a
little bit of a compressed account you
would presume also that youths are
giving their love to these older men who
are you know involved with them we saw
with Hasani as a speech that there's the
possibility of this being something not
just a sexual relationship of something
like a mentoring relationship as well
for Aristophanes this is all based in
this affection in this this desire
that's taking place so finding the
missing hang off is the goal and when
that happens he says then there's
there's not just one kind of effect he
uses three different terms here in the
Greek I didn't put them up here just for
spacial reasons not having enough room
on the chalkboard but he uses three
different words and this is worth
lingering on he talks about friendship
philia and then he also talks about
companionship boy Quixote's which
literally means you know the feeling of
being
of the same eCos of the same house we
might say being on the same team
belonging to the same group and then he
also talks about love eros oftentimes
people want to try to contrast you know
the three loves or the four laws you
know a philia eros I get paid I could
pay by the way and this is just used in
the sense of desire it's not used as the
sort of thing that the New Testament
will do with it
particularly Paul's letters these are
important different modalities but
Aristophanes is saying all of these are
going to be present the lovers who find
each other do in fact have erotic desire
for each other or if you prefer the term
lust they they lost after each other
they they desire each other in that
romantic erotic way they also are
friends they have that other effect of
friendship philia of you know being
connected with each other which is not
based on a lack of something a desire
for what's there in the other it's more
recognition of what's shared between the
two the sharing also takes part in this
way okay's the companionship which you
know has the sense of you know being in
the same place with each other when we
say being on the same page that would be
another way of translating this
companionship
all of those are present when the person
meets his is as we say soulmates right
his missing half the part that will make
him complete as a person and make that
other person complete as well remember
this is a reciprocal relationship both
sides are getting the same thing out of
it so it's not primarily as he says
about sexual desire it's not even about
the companionship that are the intimacy
the beating with each other that is much
broader than sexual activity I mean you
can how long can you have sex each day
or you know flirt with each other or do
that sort of stuff you certainly can't
do it all day long you
a honeymoon period you can but sooner or
later you've got to do other things and
you know that's when we talk about
intimacy or companionship or people
being friends with each other even that
is not the bottom of it what they're
really seeking is something that they
can't quite articulate which is to be
fused together into one thing one being
forever now he has some interesting
discussions here that come out of this
he says that and this reflects a the
ambivalence that was felt in Greek
society about male male relationships
not everybody approved of them and there
were a lot of modalities about how they
they could be viewed you know we're
gonna see Plato for example advocating
something that we call platonic
friendship right or platonic romantic
relations where you're not actually
sleeping with the person but you are you
are you know connected with each other
and you do feel desire for each other
some people accused the men who are
pursuing other men having relationships
with them pursuing youths pursuing even
even boys in some cases being shameless
the Greek for that is a nice cool taste
that means that they lacked a sense of
shame or you know the sense of modesty
is how sometimes translated they didn't
blush about the fact that they were
engaging in this behavior that should
have made them what inherent Stephanies
actually says well that's a mistaken
point of view literally they have been
lied to those who hold that point of
view because what's really going on is
it's not shamelessness it's not a lack
of limits it's not a lack of observing
how things ought to go in social
circumstances that's driving them so
that they're just you know their desire
is just moving them along and they're
these beasts that that aren't you know
paying attention to how proper people
act is rather something different
he says it's Darren it's it's their
manliness it is their masculinity their
very being originally male in a
different sense than the heterosexual
males who are pursuing women
and perhaps racking up conquests he
actually talks about the you know
heterosexual men tend to be adulterers
isn't see a lot of fidelity involved in
there he also talked about heterosexual
women running after men and cheating on
them with in this case it's because
they're coming from a being that is
originally totally male that they are
Deering they have thought rose
confidence they are courageous or manly
they are more masculine than the other
men so what does this mean this means
that they're ideally suited for the
political realm in which not only do you
have to contend against other men from
your own city remember this is the time
of Greek city-states so you know the
analogy to us would be thinking about
how governors sometimes have to go
square off against you know the
President of the United States or
against other governors municipalities
or or political communities would have
to you know engage in diplomacy and
engage in all sorts of relations and
negotiations and sometimes war with the
other city-states and Aristophanes is
saying men who are attracted to men and
who are pursuing that sort of stuff
they're better suited for the political
life than the men who are oriented
towards women he doesn't you know have
any discussion here about women you know
female female relationships that could
be a very interesting thing to examine
but unfortunately doesn't talk about
that the speech the other thing that he
says about this has to do with social
conventions and sexual desire and
institutions so he talks about them not
really being interested in marrying and
having children
why not because they're not interested
in having sex with women they're not
interested in having that whole panoply
of relations that go along with taking a
a wife or literally just you know in
Greek at that time it was driving a
woman home you know I don't do name
again good name
so you know children are something that
come from that that's not to say that
these men won't get married in fact they
will get married and they probably will
have children it's just they're not that
into that that's not where their central
desires are Agathon is a great example
of this by the way Agathon himself you
know it sends the flute girl to go play
with the women he has women in his house
but he's there with his bro as you might
say I'm talking you know in this
symposium with them because that's where
he really wants to be so they are forced
to have children they're forced to pass
on their you know their their gifts and
things like that to their children
hopefully boys of course in the Athenian
sense they're forced to marry by law or
a convention but if they couldn't get
away with that era stuff and he suggests
they would dispense with that all
together now you know how serious is he
about this it's it's that's an
interesting question to explore he is a
comic poet he is giving us this as part
of a whole big story he is also the one
person at the symposium who doesn't turn
out to have a lover there so these are
all things to bear in mind but this is
the connection that Aristophanes
articulates between sexual relations and
desire and pleasure manliness and
political life